[Music]
welcome back everybody to Entertainment
Tonight and I'm joined down by one of my
favorites my MV Alec how are you
we're doing okay my ex-husband and I am
so grateful that we parents the way we
do right and so I kind of get half the
week to freak out and cry by myself and
then my kids come back and I try and
keep it together I know so many people
have gotten a little bit of Solace and
you becoming a core gonna mean with the
happy birthday to me
me it is Amy Farrah Fowler singing
herself happy birthday to me and it says
like everyone with a birthday in March
or April my birthday's in December that
could be me in December my hair might be
that long again I don't know in the
meantime I am staying busy trying to
beat the pants off her former castmates
melissa rauch right now I am it's your
move
I'm ready for you they're just two of
the many celebs locked in an epic
Scrabble battle of the board's so we
teamed up with Maya and Scrabble go to
find out who's got game we did partner
with Scrabble go which is a mobile
version of everybody's favorite Scrabble
game and we're playing for charity right
now I think the fun thing is that this
is something you do at home but you can
be by yourself and you can be matched
with people you know or you can even
match with someone at your level or
higher if you'd like to lose oh I don't
even know she played the word Kent I've
also found that new modes of connecting
with people is keeping me really hopeful
right now it's really nice to learn a
new thing and learn how to communicate
with someone well thank you so much your
place yeah appreciate your time
[Music]